if you want to be more explosive more
agile faster more powerful then you need
to train your feet as well as your legs
I've already discussed in the past how
using dorsiflexion can help you to jump
higher that means you're starting with
your toes pointing upwards and then that
way having further to push your feet
down into the ground generating more
momentum and more power when you drive
the balls of the feet into the ground to
push yourself up but even without this
added step you're always using the toe
flexors when you push off the ground
training things like calf jumps will
naturally be using our toe flexor
muscles a little bit one example is the
flexor digitorum longus this is a deep
muscle of the leg that goes from the
calf specifically the tibialis posterior
found near the soleus and attaches to
the four small toes these are pretty
important for things like supporting the
arch of the foot which we've previously
discussed is crucial for engaging the
glutes to make yourself more glue to
dominance and more powerful remember the
glutes are the number one anti gravity
muscles in your body
the other important toe flexor muscle is
the flexor hallucis longus this is the
muscle that connects to the big toe and
is one of the driving forces when it
comes to pushing off the floor the way
we can think of these flexor muscles is
as a kind of bridge between the powerful
muscles of the leg and the ground in
other words you can have the most
powerful glutes and hamstrings and quads
and curves in the world but if you have
weak feet then you can't translate that
power into the ground to be as explosive
as possible improving mobility here is
also very important because if your
ankles are stiff then you can't move
your feet as freely to push yourself so
it's really important you learn to use
all these muscles in order to drive
yourself forwards and into the air as
well as to maintain proper stance and
form
studies show that toe flexor muscles do
respond to training and that this can
significantly increase jump height
distance and directional change our feet
toes and ankles have other important
roles in our performance to our toes can
splay in order to prevent us twisting
our ankle or tripping over when we land
on uneven terrain at the same time ankle
mobility allows us to push off the
ground at different angles and still
achieve a huge amount of force so of
course they play a big role when it
comes to balance and they provide us
with proprioceptive feedback about the
ground underneath us
you can even grip onto the ground using
our toes in order to gain more traction
and to push off more powerfully when
running so how do we make sure that
we're training the toe flexors and
feet in general well one tip is to make
sure the footwear you're using is able
to properly support full range of motion
I like my vivo barefoot the vibram nips
which I recently got another example is
this they use shoe which I believe is
worn by IDO portal these remove that big
thick wedge of sole that normally sits
between your foot and the ground thereby
allowing you to actually use your feet
in a useful manner to translate strength
from specific toes into the ground to
feel the ground underneath you you need
to ease yourself into this don't get a
pair of barefoot shoes right away it
starts printing but gradually look for
shoes with a thinner and thinner sole
less and less of a heel to toe drop and
a bigger toe box that way you can build
the strength gradually to avoid injury
better yet of course is to train
barefoot and that way you can really
engage your big toe in the movements
utilize the mind muscle connection to
make sure that it's involved as it
should be when squatting and jumping
again you need to be very careful easing
your way into barefoot running and the
like but you can slightly more safely
slip your shoes off if you're training
at home in your gym I'd be remiss of
course not to mention the Tarahumara
tribe who famously run huge distances
daily and part of the reason that we
think they're able to do this is because
they run in very minimal Footwear or
entirely barefoot finally if you want to
train the big toe specifically or the
smaller toes then you can do so using a
resistance band sit on the ground and
wrap the band around the toe as though
you're about to pull it into the
dorsiflexion position as you do that
gently push against the resistance with
your big toe or the for smaller toes by
flexing this works really well to
isolate those muscles but I do find that
most people are not going to have the
time to dedicate to specific foot
training like this on top of everything
else which is why I like this other
option more so ballet dancers are of
course very well known for their
impressive foot strength and there are
various different types of training they
use to develop this which will almost
certainly be the basis for a future
video one of my favorites though is
simply practicing pushing with the big
toe into the floor and holding that as a
static contraction so you can do this
anywhere you could be sitting down it
could be waiting in the queue and just
consciously push that big toe into the
ground and you can also practice
alternating between the big toe and the
four others whilst doing this or even
making fists with the toes
finally try simply going as high onto
your toes as possible and then holding
the position that's something else
do throughout the day as a form of
incidental training and of course you
should also think about the role of your
toes when you're performing any other
movement like a squat or a lunge just
make sure you're really working that
mind-muscle connection and thinking
about even this extremity and what it's
doing whilst you're moving through that
motion so if you want to see even better
gains from your explosive legs workouts
then add these exercises to the end of
routines or in and around the rest of
your training so it was just a quick tip
I hope you found that useful and
interesting let me know if I've missed
anything interesting about foot training
I'm sure I'll talk about the hyperox in
future but any other topics I'd love to
hear about I really love it when you
give me suggestions for future videos
I've had loads of great ideas some of my
best videos have been suggested by you
guys and I really appreciate it
so yeah I've got lots more like this on
the way thanks a ton for watching and
I'll see you next time bye for now
[Music]